[Music begins] [John Spouge, MD, PhD]
I have a background in
mathematics, a PhD in fact, and an MD.
And I spent a lot of the early part of the 80s
trying to combine the two backgrounds. And so,
when NCBI was created in 1989, it
was an amazing opportunity for me
because here was recognition of
both backgrounds simultaneously.
I certainly had an opportunity
to live my life as a physician,
but I felt that I could contribute by actually
moving society forward with the research.
The research that I'm doing falls into a
couple of distinct categories - virology
and taxonomy. The interest in virology made
it relatively easy for me to study COVID.
And so I actually became very interested
in the initial phase of the epidemic,
and what it could tell you about the
basic reproduction number "R-NAUGHT",
which is the basis of Public Health policy.
One of my more recent papers was to estimate
the basic reproduction number for COVID in 152
countries. It was an unusual feat because
it required regularizing a lot of data.
One of the most important areas that I have
worked on is definitely taxonomy.
The basic idea is dividing the genomes of
different species up into short
segments which you then compare to
a database to identify the species.
I am very proud of the fact that I was involved
in the conferences on plants and fungi - for
selecting the genes for identifying species
in those organisms called DNA barcoding. And
barcoding was established in animals but
not in plants or fungi. Both conferences
for barcoding needed someone to crunch the data
and I really was very glad that I could do that.
I think the future of NLM lies in
bringing a lot of the data analysis,
that we do as research now, directly into
a hospital. To be able to set up clinical
trials relatively easily, to be able to
collect data in standardized formats,
and all of these things would make
prediction and diagnosis much easier.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]